President Trump turned down a chance to
throw out the opening day pitch for the
Washington Nationals turned it down yeah
for some reason Trump doesn't want to be
surrounded by a bunch of large Hispanic
men holding baseball bats how would he
even I can't even imagine him throwing a
baseball I don't know maybe his hair
would throw it you know in New York
another Donald Trump story in New York
Donald Trump's childhood home has been
sold for over two million dollars yeah
the buyer was told imagine owning the
very room where Trump's daddy never
hugged him see he's
father please it's come out that several
of Donald Trump's businesses have ties
to be Russian mafia yeah so if you're
keeping track we're officially up to
season three of The Sopranos right now
it's three here's a crazy story
yesterday the House of Representatives
voted to get rid of Internet privacy
rules true story
yeah members cast their vote then
immediately ran home to delete their
browser histories that's a bad idea
ruining Internet privacy yes oh it's a
terrible idea
I mean it's bad for all of us yes oh but
it's particularly bad for you and me
well for you particularly well yeah sure
he's into that weird German stuff yeah
rats yeah everyone's nude except they're
wearing a Kaiser helmet ubers in the
news uber has released a report
highlighting the diversity of its
workers uber says their workers are very
diverse according to verse diversity
reports some of its drivers are in bands
while others are in improv troupes so
should really define that both cops way
you're going poor wide a new study a new
study reports that older women are doing
more and more binge drinking older women
doing one more binge drinking I asked my
mom if that was true and she said I Love
You Man
Chicago Bears quarterback Jay Cutler's
wife sure about this kind of a scandal
Chicago Bears quarterback Jay Cutler's
wife posted a nude photo of him on
Instagram yeah
the last thing Bears fans need to see is
another Jay Cutler sack
and with that joke he left television
you